We want the FetchWeatherTask to
return an array of string forecasts.
This means we need to modify
the return type of the AsyncTask to be
a string array.
The effect of this is that the
doInBackground method will now return
a string array.
In this method,
after we query the server and
then read in the input stream,
we're going to perform this code.
To parse the response from the server,
we call getWeatherDataFromJson.
We pass in the forecast JSON string,
as well as the number of forecast days.
To make sure that this is
returning the right string array,
we can go into the method, and then at
the bottom of the method, we just add
some logging statements to print out
every element of the string array.
Now, when you compile the code and
run it on your device,
you can hit the Refresh button to
pull the data from the server.
Then, if you open up log cat, you can
see that it was parsed correctly,
where you see all the forecast
entries being printed out.